hey guys I'm Ryan right and I'm Brianna
white Brianna white and the rights are
gonna check out a lullaby for a princess
animation have had many a female
subscribers ask to check this out
so I made sure to bring by a female who
kind of likes animation with us
I love animation are you kidding I know
I know you watch a lot of hentai snap by
1up box today warp out presents nice
fate has been cruel and order unkind how
can I send you
the stillness I'll bring you a song and
I will you come
my otherwise if carry yourself
TripIt average
she smiled sure there is no Mooney
so we'll be
great was her reign so brilliant her
glory long as the shadows
did not take notice
sister
Jesus
it's like Mewtwo versus whoa
she didn't want to do it man
you
Oh
your dreams
tonight safe upon you
and
Oh
me and my dream
you
Wow I did not expect that when they
started uh I'm surprised wow that was
beautiful
yeah that was really beautiful me it's
incredibly depressing mm what oh yeah
but ended like a bittersweet sort of
fateful kind of way which I found
incredible why would you say that I mean
the Sun and the moon and these these
cosmic powers and you know these two
forces of nature coming together and and
how they're always warring but they
still always care about each other so
much yeah it's a really beautiful story
and timeless it's time listen it's but
it's sad though yeah I'm a bittersweet
cuz that's just sort of like with all
that pain you will also know equal joy
true that's one way to look at it or you
can look at it as the Sun and the moon
just don't get along I don't think
that's why they are triangles right it's
not just black and white yeah hey don't
quote me it's like a beautiful tale of
the Sun and the moon they manage to tail
tell a story that's also relatable and
it's like a it's like a fairy tale but
the imagery is very strikingly beautiful
like it doesn't look like hardcore like
American animation but it's kind of like
a hybrid of like anime meets American
animation the action sequences I mean
it's not like about the action but like
they were pretty cool watch it they were
epic awesome this was like an epic tale
of love and hate light and dark and yeah
the emotions that separate you because
even when you know the loving Pony or
unicorn what Queen Pony was like was
fighting like the whole time she just
clearly didn't want to fight exactly
yeah I like that elements a lot of time
in these kinds of stories even when it's
like the good guy has to fight it's like
somebody get into it like the whole time
she didn't want to fight exact and then
shipping the chance to use a starfish
she had to use a starfish yeah
starfish save the world though star
fishes are [ __ ] awesome
Volpone when I make eye contact with you
I get intimidated why cuz you got kind
of an intimidating personality wow
that's really awful to say it's not
awful it's cuz you're very confident and
you're like you know you're you're
articulate okay I hang around people who
are I think around unconfident dumb
people the fact that this is an original
song and whoever performed it just
really fabulous beautiful talented voice
I don't know like I have a background a
musical theater and I've always just
been really like emotionally influenced
by like beautiful music like this like I
definitely felt moved by this music but
I love about the song - it's just a damn
good song Lee I could listen to this
song with or without and it's also
applicable yeah to a lot of things
besides the fact you know what they're
talking about ponies mm-hmm yeah that's
the other aspect that I didn't really
expect of it you know I'm not really
into the whole my little pony craze and
I was a little bit worried that's what
this was gonna be about but I liked that
it wasn't yeah like I like I'm gonna
tell my little palm into furries you
know like you know like dressing up like
an animal like that's not like a pony
and then like [ __ ] a hippopotamus you
know like that's awesome
so normal it's normal it's normal you
know it's like if someone let's dress up
as a [ __ ] hippo and then I dress up
like a gazelle and then we [ __ ] it's
like you know the circle of life
circular widened to be nature you know
some people some men want to be woman
someone wanna be men I want to be a
cheetah I'm changed by animal three
times anyway guys thanks for tuning in
to the channel if you're new to it you
can subscribe today and become a reject
ina another bad one
no no no Jack Dinah no yeah a read Jack
Tina and then you do the Hunger Games
sign wouldn't it be more like this
Jack Dana no no no not my Jennifer
Lawrence uses three fingers for a reason
and Brianna white you could check out
her sibling rivalry channel get your
aged with your siblings on hey what a
video to promote sibling rivalry like
this Elsa Anna feel it does have an else
on if I was thinking of frozen when I
was watching this for sure yeah and then
I thought a Cain and Abel and then I
thought of my brother and I cuz we do
that all the time the amount of starfish
I have to deflect my brother's violent
rage free attacks here more
yeah yeah the face sheet strand my heart
not on to my brother
oh god no oh this video Thomas videos
done